[موسيقى]
توقعتكم اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من
الرياض التي نقدم من خلالها ابرز اخبار
ملفات السعوديه والخليج وهذه ابرز وعناوين
اليوم
ختامه مؤتمر ميونخ للامن توافق غربي على
مواصله الدعم لكيف ودعوات اوروبيه للتسلح
ما بعد الزلزال المدمر تركيا تبدا رحله
التقييم وعوده 10,000 سوري من تركيا
عمان تسجل هزه ارضيه باكثر من اربع درجات
على مقياس ريختر تاكيد حكومي على بساطتها
وفي الرابعه كذلك
مشروع لتحويل فائض الاطعمه والمشروبات الى
سوق غير ربحيه شرق السعوديه
حياكم الله قبل قليل المؤتمر ميونخ للامن
في المانيا وفي كلمه له في المؤتمر شدد
مسؤول سياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي
جوزي بوريل على ضروره تطوير دور التكتل
الدفاعي والسبراني وخلال الكلمه اكد بوريل
ضروره زياده وتسريع المساعدات العسكريه
الاوروبيه لاوكرانيا اضاف المسؤول
الاوروبي انه على دول الاتحاد الاوروبي ان
ترسل ما لديها من الذخيره ثم تستبدلها ولا
تنتظر كي تشتري ذخائر جديده وترسلها وقال
بوريل انه على المدى المتوسط يجب زياده
قدره الانتاج الدفاعي الاوروبي شريطه ان
تكون هنا كذا خائير كافيه لكافه الدول على
حد تعبيره
روسيا تحاول تحويل المعركه مع اوكرانيا
الى حرب اشمل مع الغرب وعلى الدول
الاوروبيه تقاسم الاعباء الدفاعيه والدفاع
عن قيم ومبادئ الامم المتحده كما يجب
تطوير دور التكتل الدفاعي والسبراني خلال
الفتره المقبله الى جانب التركيز على
تقديم المزيد من الذخائر لاوكرانيا
ومن ميونخ تنضم الينا مراسله العربيه
راغده بهنام راغده مساء الخير مرحبا بك
معنا في نشره الرابع من الرياض ما الذي
يمكن اجماله في اليوم الاخير لمؤتمر ميونخ
للامن
راغده طيب يبدو اننا
نواجه مشكله في الصوت والصوره من من
المصدر سنعود مره اخرى الى الزميله راغده
بهنام حاله جاهزه هذا المباشر وفي هذه
النشره ايضا قال المتحدث باسم الكريم
للناديمتري بيسكوف ان روسيا لا ترى اي
انفتاح على مبادرات السلام من جانب الغرب
بخصوص اوكرانيا واضاف بيسكو فان تصريحات
وكيله وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه للشؤون
السياسيه فيكتوريا نولاند حول اعتبار
القرم هدفا مشروعا لكيف واشنطن تؤكد عمق
الخلاف بين امريكا وروسيا مشددا على ان
هذه التصريحات تعكس دور واشنطن الرئيسي في
اثاره التوترات العالميه
يعود مره اخرى الى زميل راغده بهنام والتي
تلتحق بنا من ميونخ راغده مرحبا بك معي في
نشره الرابعه من الرياض اليوم اختتم
المؤتمر مؤتمر ميونخ للامن ما الذي يمكن
اجماله في اليوم الاخير
راغده
طيب يبدو ان الزميل راغدا نواجه مشاكل
تقنيه معها من المصدر سنحاول العوده اليها
ان امكن في هذه النشره وفي ذات المؤتمر
شدد وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل
بن فرحان على ان العوده للاتفاق النوويه
الايراني يجب ان تكون بنظره شموليه
وبمشاركه خليجيه جاء ذلك اثناء جلسه
حواريه شارك فيها في مؤتمر ميونخ للامن
وزير الخارجيه السعودي اكد ان موقف
السعوديه واضح من العلاقات مع ايران مشيرا
الى وجود حوار معها وحول الوضع في الشرق
الاوسط بين الامير فيصل بن فرحان ان
الرياضه تعمل مع واشنطن على قضايا تخص امن
واستقرار المنطقه مع مراعاه المصالح
القوميه
حول الوضع في سوريا قال وزير الخارجيه
السعوديه الامير فيصل بن فرحان ان اجماعا
عربيا بدات تشكل والتزايد حول انعدام جدوى
عزل سوريا وان الحوار مع دمشق مطلوب في
وقت ما حتى تتسنى على الاقل معالجه
المسائل الانسانيه الاكثر اهميه بما في
ذلك عوده اللاجئين خاصه بعد وقوع زلزال
المدمر في سوريا وتركيا الامير فيصل اوضح
ايضا ان حاجه الدول العربيه لحل جديد في
سوريا يتزايد في ظل غياب السبل لتحقيق
الاهداف القصوى من اجل حل سياسي حول سؤاله
عن تقارير تتحدث عن انه قد يزور دمشق بعد
ان زارها نظيره الاماراتي والاردني بعد
الزلزال قال الامير فيصل بن فرحان انه لن
يعلق على الشائعات
مره اخرى نعود الى الزميله راغده بهنان من
ميونخ راغده مرحبا بك هل تسمعينني اولا
اليوم اختتم هذا المؤتمر مؤتمر ميونخ
للامن
تصريحات اللقاءات ايضا ربما مواضيع كانت
بارسه بارزه على يعني جدول هذه
الجدول هذا المؤتمر التي عقدت في بلدي
يمكن اجماله في اليوم الاخير راغده
[موسيقى]
بالفعل الحرب في اوكرانيا كانت طاغيه على
اعمال هذا المؤتمر منذ اليوم الاول وحتى
اليوم الاخير في الواقع ربما كان بارز
ايضا بانه هناك خلافات ربما تتعمق اكثر
بين الدول الغربيه والصين بسبب علاقه
الصين مع روسيا كان هناك يوم امس لقاء
مساء بينكن وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
والمبعوث الصيني المسؤول الصيني الموجود
هنا وانجلي ولكن يعني اليوم كان ليكن يقول
في مقابله لقناه امريكيه بانه هو ابلغ
المسؤول الصيني بانه اذا ما خطط الصين
خطوه اضافيه وزودت روسيا بمعدات عسكريه او
بمساعدات عسكريه فهذا سيؤثر بشكل كبير على
العلاقه الثنائيه بين الولايات المتحده
وبين الصين ويعني ايضا قال بانه ابلغه او
يعني اعتراض الولايات المتحده على مساله
البالون الصيني الذي يعني شكل كان في
عناوين الاخبار الاسبوع الماضي ولكن من
جهه اخرى ايضا كنا سمعنا من المبعوث
المسؤول الصيني هنا انتقادات شديده اللهجه
الولايات المتحده وصف رد فعلها على مساله
البالون بانه رد فعل هستيري لذلك بالفعل
هناك مخاوف الان من امكانيه زياده هذا
الدور زياده هذه العلاقه او يعني ان تكون
هناك علاقه عسكريه بين الصين وروسيا من
جهه ايضا مخاوف اخرى ظهرت هنا
واضحه بانه تشكل مصدر قلق رئيسي بالنسبه
للدول الغربيه هي العلاقه العسكريه كذلك
بين روسيا وايران يوم امس يعني كان يقول
لدبلوماسي غربي رفيع بانه الان مساله
التعاطي مع ايران يعني على اجنده على
راسها هي وقطع علاقتها العسكريه بروسيا
وبانه يعني هذا الامر الان بات مصر قراب
كبير بالنسبه للدول الغربيه لذلك ربما
يمكن القول بانه التركيز الان على مواجهه
هذين التحديين الجديدين بالطبع اضافه الى
مناقشه مساله امن اوروبا الذي يعني كان
اليوم موضوع نقاش سمعنا
الاتحاد الاوروبي يدعو الدول الاوروبيه
لعدم التردد وللسرعه في ارسال الذخائر
والمساعدات العسكريه لاوكرانيا المستقبل
الاوروبي ايضا كذلك مع روسيا ربما يعني
ملامحه في هذه القمه بدات تتضح بشكل كبير
يعني لا عوده
خط رجعه للعلاقات معها وكذلك التاكيد على
ضروره زياده طبعا
الدفاعات في هذه الدول الاوروبيه زياده
الانفاق الدفاعي
وكذلك ايضا الموضوع الصيني الامريكي ما
الذي يعني من نقاشات
اهم شيء ربما على هذه المواضيع والتي
رصدتيها انت ايضا كذلك
يعني كان هناك ربما موضوع خارج هذا
الموضوع موضوع الحرف في اوكرانيا يتعلق
بايران والاحتجاجات القائمه هناك كان هناك
جلسه شارك فيها ناشطين ناشطون ايرانيون
ويعني مسؤولون في البرلمانات الاوروبيه
ربما هذه كانت الجلسه الوحيده التي لم تكن
لها علاقه مباشره يعني او من الجلسات
القليله التي لم تكن لها علاقه مباشره
بالحرب في اوكرانيا والتي تحدثت عن ضروره
ان يزيد المجتمع الغربي ادعمه للمحتاجين
وان يعزل النظام الايراني اكثر سمعنا ايضا
من رئيس او رئيس المجلس الرئاسي اليمني
ايضا يتحدث عن يعني رفض الحوثيين الانصياع
او يعني اتخاذ ايه خطوات لانهاء هذه الحرب
وقال بانه اتفاقيات ستوكه التي التزمت بها
الحكومه اليمنيه لم تجد يعني من قبل
الحوثيين اي تحرك يشير الى انهم يعني
يريدون ان يقتل انهاء هذه
هذه الحرب القائمه هناك لذلك اليوم ايضا
صباحا كان هناك جلسه تتعلق بمساله سلام في
الشرق الاوسط شارك فيها وزير الخارجيه
الاردني
وسمعنا منه تحذير بانه الوضع في يعني
الاراضي الفلسطينيه ربما يتجه نحو انتفاضه
جديده ويعني كانت هناك انتقادات لسياسه
الحكومه الاسرائيليه الحاليه بتوسيع
المستوطنات
يعني كل ما الى ذلك لذلك بالفعل بعض
المواضيع الجانبيه التي لم تكن لها علاقه
مباشره بالحرف اوكرانيا ولكن لم تاخذ حاجز
كبير من العلاقه الامريكيه الصينيه التي
توترت بعد حادثه المنطاد على كل حال شكرا
جزيلا لك من ميونخ انضمت الينا مراسله
العربيه ذبحنا
نفت وكاله الانباء الايرانيه سقوط قتلا في
الضربه الاسرائيليه على دمشق وريفها
بسوريا واشرت الى ان الهجوم الاسرائيلي
نفذ على مرحلتين الاولى في دمشق والثاني
في السويداء المزيد في هذا التقرير
تصاعد ملحوظ للضربات الاسرائيليه على
اهداف في قلب العاصمه السوريه دمشق
استهداف صاروخي تخترق به اسرائيل الاجواء
السوريه بهدف الوصول لمواقع ومنشات
وعناصره تابعه لايران الاستهداف الثاني
خلال العام الجاري هجوم صاروخي اسرائيلي
طال كفر سوسه الحي السكني في دمشق وراحه
ضحيته 15 شخصا وفقا للمرصد السوري لحقوق
الانسان تلك الصواريخ الاسرائيليه استهدفت
مواقع تتمركز فيها ميليشيات ايرانيه وحزب
الله اللبناني ويعد هذا الاستهداف
الاسرائيلي ثاني خلال العام الجاري ففي
الثاني من يناير الماضي قتل سبعه عناصر
جراءت ضربات الاسرائيليه على مطار دمشق
الدولي ومحيطه
وتيره الهجمات الاسرائيليه على اهداف داخل
سوريا وثقها المرصد السوري بحوالي 32
استهدافا خلال العام الماضي وحده قامت
خلالها اسرائيل باستهداف الاراضي السوريه
سواء عبر ضربات صاروخيه او جويه اسفرت عن
اصابه وتدمير نحو 91 هدفا عسكريا
رابع مستمر وفيها بعد قليل
ما بعد الزلزال المدمر تركيا تبدا رحله
التقييم وعوده عشرات الالاف السوريين من
تركيا
[موسيقى]
حياكم الله من جديد مع مروري 14 يوما على
الزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا
تجاوز عدد الضحايا اربعين الف قتيل والاف
المفقودين وسائل الاعلام التركيه كشفت عن
تسجيل هزه ارضيه جديده بقوه
وسبعه من عشره في ملاطيا فيما يستمر نزوح
المتضررين من الولايات المنكوبه في تركيا
الى مناطق اخرى بحثا عن ماوى ومكان اكثر
امانا وتبدا السلطات التركيه كذلك بحصر
جميع الاضرار جراء الزلزال غدا الاثنين
فيما تجري حاليا عمليات التثبت من الجثث
المجهوله عبر فحص الحمض النووي وحول هذا
الامر ايضا دعا وزير الداخليه التركي
سليمان سويلو المواطنين للتوجه الى مراكز
مخصصه في كل ولايه للحصول على عينه دم
لاجراء الفحص وتسهيل التعرف على اصحاب
الجثث مجهوله الهويه
ومعنا من غازي عنتاب زيدان زين كلو مراسل
العربيه زيدان مرحبا بك معي في نشره
الرابعه من الرياض يعني ربما اخر الهزات
الارضيه التي تم رصدها هذا اليوم هي في
منطقه ملاتيا او ملطيه في تركيا الى اي
مدى هذه الهزه كانت بشكل قوي ما الذي
رصدته حولها ايضا بدايه
نعم لا شك نايف ان الهزات الارتداديه ما
زالت تثير خوف السلطات التركيه لاسيما ان
هناك العديد وهو مئات والاف المباني
المتصدعه للسقوط هذه الهزات ان كان في
ملاطيا قبل قليل وكانت بقوه 4.7 على مقياس
ريختر او يوم امس هزه ارتداديه كانت هنا
في غازي عنتاب تجاوزت خمس درجات
تجاوزت شدتها خمس درجات على مقياس ريختر
طبعا لا شك ان كل هذه الازات يشعر بها
سكان المنطقه هذه الازاد تثير الزعر لدى
سكان هذه المناطق وايضا السلطات التي تخشى
من سقوط ابنيه جديده لذلك السلطات حصلت او
يعني تقريبا قدرت حتى الان عمليات البحث
ما زالت مستمره نايف لكن حتى الان اعداد
المباني التي تهدمت بشكل كامل او بشكل
جزئي او او مباني تصدعت ولا يمكن السكن
تجاوز عدد هذه المباني
84,600 مبنى بالتالي هذه المباني سيتم
هدمها بشكل عاجل للبدء استعدادا للبدء في
عمليه اعاده الاعمار كما نشاهد هنا في هذا
المكان الذي وصلناه قبل قليل هنا في
اصلاحيه يتم تشييد 300
مبنى جديد هي عباره عن كرفانات هنا تسمى
كرفانات وهي اماكن ايواء مؤقته لنقل 300
عائله تعيش في الخيام الى هذه المنطقه
التي نشاهدها الان الاليات تعمل على مدار
الساعه لمحاوله في محاوله انجاز هذا
الموضوع او انجاز هذا السكن المؤقت في
اسرع وقت وكما ذكرت نايف هناك حالات نزوح
كبيره من هذه المناطق الى مناطق اكثر امنا
النزوح ساعود اليك فيها زيدان لكن اريد ان
اسال عن اليه تقييم المنازل واضرار
المنازل ايضا حتى كذلك في غ عنتاب كيف
تجري هذه الامور اشرح لنا اكثر
نعم بشكل عام تم يعني تم تجنيد اكثر من
سبعه الاف مختص في كل الولايات المتضرره
لفحص كل المباني الموجوده في هذه الولايات
يتم البدء في فحص هذه المباني مراقبه
الاساسات الجدران الطوابق بشكل كامل وكل
منزل على حدها ومن ثم يتم تقييم الاضرار
بشكل عام في حال كان المبنى
يمكن اصلاحه واجراء عمليات ترميم يتم
تقييمه انه من ضمن المباني التي يمكن
ترميمها وبالتالي هذه المباني سترمم في
وقت قريب جدا اما في حال كانت المباني غير
مناسبه للسكن وفيها خطوره على سكان هذه
المنازل يتم تقييمها بانها مباني او يتم
اعطاء اشاره اليها بانها مباني ستهدم
وبالتالي يحذر على سكانها العوده اليها
وهذا طبعا ذكرت عمليه التقييم ما زالت
مستمره في كل الولايات اكثر من سبعه الاف
مختص هم من يقومون بهذه العمليه ممتاز
بالنسبه للنازحين كنت تشير الى نقطه قبل
قليل زيدان يعني اريد ان تفصل لنا فيها
اكثر طبعا هي واضحه الصور معنا الان ربما
بعض الخيام الموجوده في
في خلف طبعا
الزميل او خلف الزميل زيدان زين زين تفضل
في كل المناطق المتضرره نحن هنا في مدينه
اصلاحيه تقريبا في كل منطقه في اصلاحيه
هناك تجمع لعشرات الخيام طبعا سكان هذه
الخيام بعضهم فضل ان يذهب بشكل منفرد الى
اقاربه وذويه في ولايات اخرى لذلك حركات
النزوح ما تزال مستمره بعضهم ينتظر
المساكن المؤقته للسكن في هذه المساكن
المؤقت لك هذا المشروع الذي نشاهده امامنا
الان وبالتالي هناك سيتم ايواء الكثير من
منتظر من متضرري الزلزال في هذه المشاكل
لكن قبل قليل وفي جوله هنا في مدينه
اصلاحيه كنت التقي مع
لاجئين سوريين وهذه المدينه استضافت الاف
اللاجئين السوريين خلال السنوات الماضيه
وكثيرا كثير كثير منهم مع الاسف يعني لقي
حتفه بسبب الزلز الكثير منهم ما زال يقيم
في خيم بعضهم اخبرني ان موظفين من اداره
الهجره كانوا يجولون عليهم اثناء تواجدنا
في هذا المكان طلبوا منهم مغادره اصلاحيه
الى مخيم نيزيب في ولايه غازي عنتاب هم
يخشون حقيقه من ذهابهم الى هناك وعدم
توفير اماكن مناسبه لهم
اماكن ايواء لهم لذلك هم يتخوفون من هذه
الخطوه حاولنا ان نسال موظفي
اداره الهجره عن هذا الموضوع لكنهم لم
يؤكدوا او ينفوا هذه المعلومه وتبقى هذه
المعلومات بعهده اللاجئين الذين اخبرون
بهم لكن سالنا العديد منهم والجميع اكد
هذه المعلومه لكن موظفي اداره الهجره
رفضوا التعليق على هذا الموضوع طبعا غازي
عنتاب هي من المدن التي انتهت فيها طبعا
يعني عمليات ربما البحث او الانقاذ او
التقصي عن ناجين تحت يعني انقاذ المنازل
المهدمه زيدان
نعم نعم بالضبط قبل ايام تم الاعلان بشكل
رسمي عن انتهاء اعمال البحث والانقاذ
والان هناك تجري في بعض المواقع ازاله
الانقاض استعدادا للبدء بعمليه اعاده
الاعمار هذه العمليه التي من المنتظر ان
تبدا في مطلع مارس القادم طبعا باشراف
مؤسسه توكي وهي مؤسسه اسكان حكوميه هي
التي ستشرف على شروط تنفيذ الابنيه
ومواصفات الابنيه التي ستكون مضاده
للزلازل وتم اختيار الاراضي التي والمناطق
التي ستقام فيها المشاريع الجديده طبعا من
المنتظر ان تبدا الحكومه في مطلع مارس في
بناء 30 الف وحده سكنيه بحسب
مسؤولين حكوميين ان مناقصات ستبدا خلال
ايام قليله بشكل متزامن في عديد الولايات
على ان يتم البدء بمشاريع اضافيه
لاستكمال عمليات اعاده الاعمار خلال
الفتره لكن كما ذكرنا كل العمليات ستكون
باشراف الوزارات المعنيه وتحديدا مؤسسه
توكي هذه المؤسسه المسؤوله عن عشرات
المشاريع ومئات المشاريع في كل الولايات
التركيه وحتى الان يعني بحسب تصريحات
وتاكيدات من مسئوليتوكي ان كل المباني
والمشاريع السكنيه التي قاموا بانشائها في
الولايات العشره لم تتضرر ابدا بالزلزال
لان مواصفاتها كانت مطابقه للمعايير
الموضوعه لمكافحه الزلازل شكرا جزيلا لك
على كل هذه المعلومات والتفاصيل من غازي
عنتاب زيدان العربيه
وسط تردي ظروف المنكوبين جراء الزلزال في
سوريا دعت منظمه اطباء بلا حدود الى زياده
المساعدات الانسانيه الى شمال غرب سوريا
بشكل عاجل اشاره المنظمه الى انه في
الايام العشره التي اعقبت الزلزال كان عدد
الشاحنات التي عبرت الى شمال غرب سوريا
اقل من معدلها الاسبوعي في العام 2022
ياتي ذلك تزامنا مع دخول اربع عشره شاحنه
للمنظمه محمله بالف ومئتين وتسعه وستين
خيمه ومستلزمات لمواجهه البرد لنازحين
وعائلات شردها الزلزال عبر معبر الحمام في
منطقه عفرين كانت المنظمه استنفدت مخزونها
في ادلب بعد وقوع الزلزال عبر تقديم حوالي
12 طنا و4000 متر مكعب من المعدات
الجراحيه والادويه لمستشفيات ادلب
من جانبها قالت نائبه المبعوث الوني الخاص
لسوريا نجاه رشدي ان الامم المتحده ملتزمه
تماما ببذل المزيد لمساعده جميع السوريين
مضيفه ان في سوريا تاثر ما لا يقل عن
ثمانيه ملايين شخص بالزلزال المدمر كما من
المتوقع ان يحتاج غالبيتهم الى شكل من
اشكال المساعدات الانسانيه
اشار وزير الدفاع التركي اخص اكاري الى
عوده اكثر من عشره الاف سوريين في تركيا
الى سوريا طوعا دون الاشاره الى مزيد من
التفاصيل وذلك منذ ان ضرب زلزال عنيف
اجزاء واسعه من جنوب تركيا وشمال غرب
سوريا ووفقا لبيانات الامم المتحده تعد
تركيا اكبر الدول المضيفه للاجئين
السوريين في العالم وفقا لبيانات الامم
المتحده
وعلى صعيد الجهود الاغاثيه يقدم مستشفى
صحه الافتراضي التابع لوزاره الصحه
السعوديه خدماته للمتضررين من الزلزال عبر
تقديم الاستشارات الطبيه والفحوص عن بعد
المدير التنفيذي الطبي لمستشفى صحه
الافتراضيه الدكتور عبد العزيز الحمود
يعطينا لمحه عن اليه عمل المستشفى
العمل هذا
يتطلب تضافر جهود ممكن فريق الهلال الاحمر
موجود على الارض
بتواصل مباشر مع المتضررين من هالكوارث
وهالزلازل وبدعم من
وتنسيق بمركز الملك سلمان الاغاثه
باستخدام التقنيه لدينا الاجهزه لدينا
وسائل تجهيز العياده التقنيه والافتراضيه
عن بعد هناك وطبيب من الموجود في المستشفى
الافتراضي يستطيع التواصل مع المريض بشكل
مباشر مثل المستشفى الافتراضي او الاطباء
الموجودين جزء منهم من فريق المستشفى
والجزء الاخر تم استقطارهم عن طريق برامج
اخرى متوفره في السعوديه تق شامل للحاله
تقوم باستخدام بعض التقنيات للفحص الدقيق
حتى نبض القلب او ما الى ذلك يستطيع
طبيبنا هنا عن طريق التواصل يسمع ويفحص
القلب يفحص النبضات يفحص التنفس يوفر
الدواء ينصح بالخطوه القادمه الحمد لله كل
هذه تكون متوفره من هنا الحمد لله
بعده الرابع
ختامه مؤتمر ميونخ للامن توافق غربي على
مواصله الدعم لكييف ودعوات اوروبيه للتسلح
ما بعد الزلزال المدمر تركيا تبدا رحله
التقييم وعوده عشره الاف سوري من تركيا
عمان تسجل هزه ارضيه باكثر من اربع درجات
على مقياس ريختر تاكيد حكومي على بساطتها
مشروع لتحويل فائض الاطعمه والمشروبات الى
سوق غير ربحيه شرقي السعوديه
حياكم الله في اخبار الزلازل اعلنت سلطنه
عمان عن تسجيل هزه ارضيه بقوه 4.1 درجات
على مقياس ريختر وفقا لمركز رصد الزلزال
او الزلازل في جامعه السلطان قابوس فان
الهزه سجلت في مدينه الدقم على الساحل
الجنوبي الشرقي للسلطنه وبين المركز ان
الشعور بالهزه كان خفيفا في الدقم وغير
محسوس في المدن الاخرى بما فيها العاصمه
مسقط واشار المرصد الى ان الشده الزلزاليه
تختلف من موقع الى اخر ومن مبنى الى اخر
وفقا لارتفاعها وطبيعه التربه
مرحبا بك اخ نايف الساده المشاهدين طبعا
حدث هزه ارضيه صباح اليوم بالسبعه وخمسه
بمقدار
اربع واحد بالعشره بمقياس ريختار الزلازل
كانت على عمق 18 كيلو متر هذا العمق يعتبر
عميق الى حد ما حيث تبدل معظم الطاقه
تمتصها الارض ويصل منها جزء بسيط على على
سطح الارض على شكل هزات
حدث في محافظه الوسطى وهي محافظه غير
ماهوله وهذا الزلزال من النوع الخفيف عاده
حتى لو شعر بير مواطنين وزلزال غير مؤثر
الا على بهالشكل محدود جدا على المباني
الطينيه او المتهالكه والزلزال سجل لكن
غير محس غير غير مؤثر وبالتالي هذا يعني
هذا المستوى من الهزات الارضيه لا يوجد له
هزات ربما ارتداديه او تبعات خطيره دكتور
نعمل هزات الهزات معظم الهزات الارضيه
الكبيره او كل الهزات الارضيه الكبيره لها
توابع ذات الخفيفه مثل هذه نادر ما يكون
الها توابع واذا كان خفيفه جدا جدا او
ضعيفه في مستوى لا يمكن الاحساس بها فقط
باجهزه الرصد الزلازل الحساسه جدا
الزلازل الخفيفه التوابع انها تتوقع ان
يحدث لها
طيب دكتور يعني علميا هل يمكن
يعني الربط بينما حدث في تركيا وسوريا
اتحدث هنا عن الربط يعني
المنطقه ككل بانها ربما تعيش مرحله من
مرحله الهزات او الزلازل او او ما الى ذلك
لانها لم تسجل الهزات فقط مثلا في في
سوريا وتركيا سجلت في دول اخرى ايضا في
محيطها
نعم هو احنا نتكلم عن الصفيحه العربيه
والصفيحه العربيه صحيح مترابطه طبعا واللي
ما حدث في الشمال
غرب الصفيحه العربيه في شمال شمال غرب
سوريا والجنوب شرق تركيا او جنوب تركيا هو
الجزء الشمالي الغربي من الصفيحه العربي
احنا
عاده البحوث العلميه تثير تشير الى بعض
الاحيان انه بعض الزلازل تحفز الزلازل
اخرى على صدور اخرى على الاغلب تكون
الصدوع قريبه منها يعني يسمونه
انكسر
الضغوط خفت عليه صدى اخر مجاور او بالقرب
منه
ينشط زلزاليا اما بهذا البعد مسافه تقريبا
اكثر من 3000 كيلو تقريبا من
سبع شرق الاناضول
ووسط المحافظه بعيد جدا لاحتمال مثل هذا
يعني حتى لو كان محفز يعني هو تحفيز بسيط
جدا يعني القوه الناتجه على التحفيز بهذا
المجال هي اجزاء بسيطه عشريه من البار
فتكون ضعيفه جدا طيب
علمي انه الزلازل تحرض بعضها على
الانتاجيه بس بعد المكاني بل بعد الجغرافي
نستبعد انه هذا التحريض من زلزال تركي
وبالتالي التحريض من الزلزال تركيا ربما
يكون دكتور للدول المعاديه او القريبه
مثلا من سوريا
الى الغاب بالسوريه الى جنوب شرق تركيا
لهذا يعتبر يعتبر خط زلزال طويل جدا مشابه
له في بين البحر العربي والمحيط الهندي
اللي يمتد من الصومال الى باكستان هذول
الصدعين هم يستاهلون انزلاق الصفيحه
العربي باتجاه
الشرق والشمال الشرقي
اللي حدث عليه زلزال تركيا
يعني صنع شرق قال انا اظن وامتداد جنوبا
الى خليج العقبه يعني ممكن يحفز زلازل في
لبنان في سوريا في فلسطين
وعاده تكون متتابعه وتكون زلازل صغيره
للمت اغلبها تكون صغيره ممكن تكون محسوسه
لكن غير مؤثره الا على الاباني التي هي
انهكت وصارت يعني اصبحت متهالكه او انت
تقصد يا دكتور بانها غير محسوسه لان اليوم
اداره هيئه الكوارث التركيه مثلا اعلنت
بان هناك سته الاف واربعين هزه ارتداديه
سجلت بعد زلزال المدمر والعنيف الذي ضرب
في السادس من فبراير وبالتالي انا اساس
الارتداديه دكتور هل هل تكون في محيط
الزلزال ام ابعد من من هذه المنطقه
الجغرافيه
كل الزلازل الكبيره تحدث الا عندها
التوابع والتوابع احيانا تكون كبيره الى
حد ما وتكون مؤثره والكثير منها يكون
زلازل صغيره لانه الزلزال الضخم هو فرغ
معظم الطلب وكسر اكبر نتوء على سطح الفالق
اما النتوءات الاخرى على سطح الفالق
فتتالا بانكسارها
ممكن بعضها الاكبر وبعضها الاصغر وحجم هو
ينتج منها زلزال متوسط الى زلازل خفيفه
الاحساس بالزلزال لا يعني ان الزلزال مؤثر
يعني مرت من جنبنا شاحنه او قطار نشعر
باهتزاز المبنى فهذا اهتزاز
موكل زلزال تشعر به انه يعني يجب ان يكون
مؤثرا على المبنى يعني احنا نعيش في بيئه
والبيئه مترابطه الاهتزاز احيانا يكون صحي
لانه تنفس الزلازل
يعني تنتج الضغوط على الصدع بشكل جرعات
وتكون زلازل صغيره احسن ما تتجمع وتصير
زلزال اكبر دكتور انتم من خلال رصدكم يعني
في جامعه السلطان قابوس في رصه الزلازل
وبالنسبه لعمان او ايضا حتى دول
الخليج هل يعني تتوقعون او مثلا ترصدون او
تتنبؤون ايضا بالزلازل قبل ان تقع
بخطورتها ايضا كذلك نريد ان نفهم هذه
النقطه لانها مثار للدكتور دائما انه هل
يمكن التنبؤ بالزلزال ام استحاله التنبؤ
فيه ايضا وفي نطاقه الجغرافي كذلك
وسائل جيد يطرح دائما هو التنبؤ بالزلزال
الى الان العلم لم يتوصل الى الى طريقه
علميه متسقه وموثقه تتنبا بالزلزال هناك
ظواهر قبل الزلزال العلماء عاده وصلوا الى
نوع من التوقع يتوقع النطاقات الزلزله
ويحددوا اكبر قدر زلزالي على كل نطاق
زلزالي اما التنبؤ بالزمان هذا اللي الى
الان استحاله تحديد التنب واحد يكون
التنبؤ مفيد الي والك وللمشاهدين
والمهندسين لازم يتوفر في عناصر الوقت وهو
لازم كل هذا الوقت حتى يكون مفيد
والمكان والقوه واحتماليه وقوع هذا الزفاف
اذا ما توفرت كل هذه العناصر واهمها الوقت
يبقى
نسميه توقع او فوركاس فقط اشكرك جزيل
الشكر من مسقط انضمي لان الدكتور عيسى
الحسين مدير مركز رصد الزلازل بجامعه
السلطان قابوش بقابوس
اطلقت جمعيه اطعام في المنطقه الشرقيه اول
سوبر ماركت غير ربحي وسيموفي في حفظ
الموارد الغذائيه من الهدر وتقديم حلول
التامين الغذائي المستدام للاسر المستفيده
والافراد واول سوبر ماركت سحابيه عبر
سلسله فروع لتطوير الخدمات الدعم الغذائي
وتوفير منافذ التوزيع السحابيه لفروع
اطعام
بجمعيه بنك الطعام السعودي اطعام
ومن مقر جمعيه اطعام بالدمام ينضموا الينا
مراسل العربيه عبد الرحمن العصيمي عبد
الرحمن مساء الخير مرحبا بكم معي في نشاط
الرابعه من الرياض عبد الرحمن ماذا لديك
اليوم انت ربما موجود في بنك الطعام هذا
غير الربح
نعم نايف نحن من وحده التعبئه المركزيه في
جمعيه اطعام هذه الجمعيه التي شكلت نموذج
ناجحا لعمل الجمعيات الخيريه عبر تطور
العمل بها منذ تاسيسه حتى اليوم هذا
النجاحات اليوم تبلورت في اعلان عدد من
المبادرات وعدد من الشراكات ومذكرات
التفاهم عدد من القطاعات الحيويه في
السعوديه لعل ابرزها هو السوبر ماركت غير
الربحي السحابي الذي سيشكل نقل نوعيه في
جمعيات اطعام المحتاجين والمستفيدين بدايه
دعنا نستضيف الاستاذ
منصور
الشوشان فيصل الشوشان عذرا فيصل بدايه
الرئيس التنفيذي طبعا لجمعيه الطعام لماذا
هذا التوجه اليوم
وفيما يتعلق بالسواكه السحابي وغير الربح
طبعا سنشاهد بعد قليل لقطات لهذا السوبر
ماركت الذي كان نموذج اليوم في
توسعت عملياتنا بشكل كبير تنوعت المنتجات
في تداخل كبير في الاغذيه دخولنا على
الطعام الجاف جهود الدوله اليوم في مساله
الامن الغذائي رؤيه احد محاولها الرئيسيه
هو دعم الامن الغذائي في حراك كبير في هذا
الملف لابد ان اكون جزء نحن من هذا الحراك
نعمل على الابتكار في صناعه النماذج
المبتكره في القطاع غير ربحي تخصصنا في
الغذاء قررنا التوجه بهذه الطريقه وهو
توجه خاص باطعام ولد من الجمعيه من الداخل
ان ننتقل الى هذا الى هذا التوقيت في هذا
التوقيت الى هذه المرحله اعتقد بمشيئه
الله تعالى خلال الربع الثاني من العام
الجاري 2022
23 سيتم ان شاء الله تشغيل اول
فروع طعام اكسبرس في مدينه الدمام ومن ثم
سوف تكون هنالك سلسله فروع سواء في
المنطقه الشرقيه وفي باقي مناطق المملكه
ان شاء الله شكرا استاذ فيصل طبعا نايف
هذه الجمعيه لديها ناجحه جدا فيما يتعلق
بالمتاجر الالكترونيه كما نشاهد هذا موقع
الجمعيه
نجحوا سابقا في تقديم عدد من الباقات
من يرغب بالتبرع واختيار السلال بعد شهر
ونصف تقريبا ستبدا هذه الجمعيه بتطبيق
المتجر السحابي عبر تطبيق
خاص عبر الاجهزه
الذكيه
للبدء بهذه الخطوه التي ستشكل نقله كبيره
في
جمعيات الاطعام في السعوديه سادع زميلي
نصر ياخذ لكم بعض اللقطات كما نشاهد نحن
في وحده تعبئه مركزيه نايف هذه الصناديق
تذهب الى المستفيدين اولا باول من خلال
الادويه او السوري الاغذيه
الخاصه
بهم طبعا هذا المتجر نايف ما هي الفائده
منه انت عندما تريد ان تتبرع
للمحتاجين والمستفي تدخل الى السوبر ماركت
وتقول انا اليوم اريد التبرع مثلا بحليب
اطفال فقط او اريد التبرع مثلا بخضار او
فواكه فقط فتختار
البضائع او الاغذيه التي تريدها بالتحديد
ومن ثم تذهب الى المستفيدين ايضا سيتم
اختيار بعض المناطق الاكثر احتياجا ويتم
افتتاح السوبر ماركت فيها يستطيع المستفيد
بعبر بطاقه تموينيه ان ياتي الى هذا
سوماركت وياخذ ما يريد من الاغذيه
والاطعمه طبعا اون لاين يستطيع ان يحصل
على هذه الاغذيه فعمل كبير ومؤسساتي وجهد
صراحه منقطع النظير من قبل هذه الجمعيه
لتقديم تجربه فريده وناجحه صحيح وواضح
طبعا يا عبد الرحمن شكرا جزيلا لك من مقر
جمعيه اطعام بالدمام انضم الينا مراسل
العربيه عبد الرحمن
[موسيقى]
في سوق العملات المشفره استمرت سلسله
الارتفاعات على اغلب العملات خاصه عمله
البيتكوين مع ارتفاع شهيه المستثمرين
للمخاطره على الرغم من تحركات ماليه
الرقابيه امريكيه استهدفت اساس هذه السوق
وهي العملات المستقره المزيد في هذا
التقرير
بعد الارتفاعات الكبيره لسوق العملات
المشفره في يناير والتي تجاوزت الاربعين
في المئه لعمله البيتكوين المحرك الرئيس
لهذه السوق يبدو ان زخم هذه الارتفاعات لم
يهدا بعد على الرغم من توجهات رقبيه وعلى
راسها الامريكيه بتضييق الخناق على هذا
السوق ففي الايام الاخيره امر كل من هيئه
الاوراق الماليه والبورصات واداره الخدمات
الماليه في ولايه نيويورك ان واي دي اف اس
شركه باكسوس المرخصه بوقف اصدار عمله بي
يو اس دي المستقره والتي تتبع اكبر منصه
تداول في العالم
هجوم السلطات الرقابيه الماليه جاء بحجه
تصنيف هذه العمله على انها ورقه ماليه غير
مرخصه وهذا ما قد يفتح الباب واسعا امام
تصنيف جميع العملات المستقره كاوراق ماليه
وفي هذه الحاله فان اس اي سي المسؤوله عن
تنظيمها بل وايقافها في حال مخالفتها
قواعد الهيئه ما ان جاء القرار بايقاف
باكسوس وعمله حتى دفعت الثمن سريعا بتراجع
عملتها بي ان بي تراجعا حاديا تجاوز 15%
لكن المؤسسه سيزي غرد سريعا لانقاذ الموقف
وتوضيحه بان بايننس قد تبحث عن عمله
مستقره اخرى بعيدا عن الولايات المتحده
لضمان العمليات والعملاء وهو منعكس على
وقف نزيف بي ام بي على الاقل في الوقت
الحالي استهداف السلطات الرقابيه الماليه
لسوق الكريبتو هذه المره جاء بنتائج عكسيه
فحظر عمله بي يو اس تي دفع المستثمرين الى
تحويل حيازتهم فيها الى عمله مشفره اخرى
امن منها وبالطبع كانت عمله البيتكوين
افضل الخيارات بجانب عمله يو اس دي تي
المستقره وهو ما دعم الارتفاعات
تحرك سوق العملات المشفره يعتمد على شهيه
المخاطره للمستثمرين وهو ما دعمه ارتفاع
الاسواق الماليه وتراجع التضخم وتخفيف
الاحتياطي الفيدرالي للهجته في رفح اسعار
الفائده لكن السلطات الرقابيه ما زالت ترى
بان تنظيم السوق على راس اولوياتها وذلك
لمحاربه السرقه وغسيل الاموال شادي الزعيم
العربيه
انقسم العرب المطر الى ثمانيه اقسام منها
الردادو والديم والوابل التفاصيل مع خالد
الزعل
[موسيقى]
لا يوجد امه من الامم اهتمت بتفاصيل
ودقائق السماء من نجم وسدم ورعد وبرق كحال
الامه العربيه ليش لانهم اهل تنقل وترحل
في صحراء متراميه الاطراف ومتشابهه
المعالم فهم يعتمدون على النجوم في تنقلهم
وترحلهم وفصولهم ومواسمهم فعلاقتهم
بالسماء علاقه حياتيه وجوديه تطورت الى
علاقه وجدانيه اقلب طرفي في السماء لعله
يوافق طرفي طرفها
حين تنظروا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
والعرب قسموا المطر الى الرذاذ قطرات
المطره خفيفه والعامه يسمونه بالذرذر الرش
هو المطر الخفيف الدين هو المطر الدائم
الهتان هو المطر المتتابع الوابل هو
المطره غزير ذات الحبه الكبيره الحياه هو
الذي يحيي الارض الغيث هو الذي ياتينا بعد
انقطاع طويل الغدق المطر الغزير وان لو
استقاموا على الطريقه لاسقيناهم ماء غدقه
[موسيقى]
ختام الرابعه بابرز عناوينها
ختامه مؤتمر ميونخ للامن توافق غربي على
مواصله الدعم لكيف ودعوات اوروبيه للتسلح
ما بعد الزلزال المدمر تركيا تبدا رحله
التقييم وعوده عشره الاف سوري من تركيا
ارضيه باكثر من اربع درجات على مقياس
ريختر تاكيد حكومي على بساطتها
مشروع لتحويل فائده الاطعمه والمشروبات
الى سوق غير ربحيه شرقي السعوديه
شكرا لكرمي لطفي المتابعه نهايه الرابعه
في امان الله
[موسيقى]